ce soir les enfants
j'espère que nicolas et pimprenelle ont
été sages aujourd'hui qu'en penses-tu
nounours bien sûr qu'ils ont été sages
patron je descends tout de suite et voir
mon échelle popopopop au bon d'accord
nicolas angers ont fait table rase et
moi je vais m'habiller comme les dames
qui sont dans les journaux de maman bon
dépêche toi car je suis prêt bon soit au
pardon je me trompe je suis chez un
photographe qui trompe banos en soir tu
es chez le grand photographe nicolas et
tu tombes bien tu va m'aider oui
monsieur nicolas je vais être votre
assistant nous allons photographier
mademoiselle mademoiselle capitale
mademoiselle k tinga ne bougeait plus
regardée via un petit oiseau qui va
sortir
coucou c'est moi le petit oiseau toi tu
tiens cette branche
comme s'il y avait un homme à côté
d'elle oui monsieur
voilà comme ça très bien ne bougeait
plus
sipa saleh maximilian schell s'attaquera
pas pr neil je ne t'avais pas reconnu
mais qu'importe où vivent ne bouge pas
reste comme ça tu es très bien j'ai une
photo je suis photogénie c'est pas ça y
est et voici il a dit fleurs toinon 9 tu
tiens ça tomberait comme ça parfait vous
êtes très mots je souris superbe
ça y est ouf
il est lourd ce parapluie c'est une
ombre al nounou vous êtes prêts voilà il
a ni kogure super super c'est bon sens
je pose lui petit polo et voilà la dix
mille fleurs au sol au matin couper
toutes les fleurs de la maison on veut
je vais voir et site occupé toute la
flore que je plante ailleurs au bon
moment et nous nous donnons je crois
qu'il vaut mieux que j'aille me coucher
je le dis sur ngp tous mes fleurs
enfin sa salle le dépôt de fleurs
kouamelan vie comme je te donnerai tout
est vrai vous n'allez pas vous disputez
vous avez fait de très jolies photos
oui mais tu sais bien très bon
photographe nicolas allons en
dormez-vous vie là j'étale a lieu
bonne nuit balonmano panis-nicolas
ennuis le dépôt de fleurs
[Musique]
bonne nuit les enfants
il ne faut jamais se disputer c'est très
vilain au oui
cette trêve il allez vite vous coucher
et fait beau rêve
[Musique]
e
où
encore
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]